what that's not how does that work wait
hang on
I did oh my god that's that doesn't seem
right
ha ha wait ah ok that's good enough I
guess let me put a nice nice big red M
here and that up and we're good hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to human fall flat now this game
is a beta I believe ow my bones my
pelvis and my legs they've all exploded
out of my body and also I'm just
horrifying
I love that I got a face on the back of
my head oh yeah that's how normal people
walk
activate the blow hey you just had an
instructional video oh did I
I don't wanna okay whenever you're lost
or otherwise in despair look around for
such remotes once activated
I don't provide instructions ranging
from very helpful to totally useless
brain if there is no remote around you
you may return to initial despair or you
may start looking for ways to solve the
puzzle instead okay thank you God every
time I look at my face on the back of my
character's head it's completely
horrifying hawaii's are an M both on the
front and the back ha hey hey Leo
everybody into every door they encounter
uh-huh am i human not entirely sure
that's how this works
up I can jump I can wobble I can lose a
lot of these little they see well that's
a sweeping generalization some might
call that horrible racism I'm not sure
and direction as you may have noticed
you will reach for things that you're
looking at Rockwell I you can't grab
something or push a button yeah
don't blame your hands on your head oh
you may need to look up to grab
something that is high uh-huh and you
will have to bend over to reach
something that is on the floor okay
don't worry this is a safe place I'm not
a hundred percent sure about that
because I don't even think my body is
safe at the moment with the [ __ ]
that's going on with it
but I'm undoubtedly more complier like
that's the one thing that I can say
about this hey push that button we will
push that button to achieve your goals
that's us humans we like to him we like
to pee in founds apparently that just
looks nothing more like a giant toilet
great do I go do these at the same time
that's what I guess heavily heavily I
don't grab opportunities with both your
hands uh-huh oh [ __ ]
yah aah
I'm gonna miss nope I landed Wow
it looks like that train station
accident that famous victory so what am
I supposed to be doing
do I have an objective okay on through
the door now this is completely utterly
Dickens when I got this game I had no
idea what it was about and I'm still
just as lost as I was back then oh it's
a puzzle wonder what I'm gonna start
falling flat here Pepa Davidov don't
mind me my hands are the same color as
the soundproofing in my room what
happens if I go sailing off the edge
uh apparently nothing oh oh I loop back
to the exact same place I oh my god the
bottom of my hat that even is my hat
holy [ __ ] uh goodbye hello I can't
escape this hell I just want to be free
oh let me leave this torment for
haha I mean I gotta admit I'm very
strong and I got quite the but if I'm
gonna be able to ship well god damn it
let me strut my way to the next area
haha ski [ __ ] god damn it I don't like
such a street alright three two one air
come success yay and boy yay I did it I
don't even know if I was where I was
supposed to do it I didn't even read
what it said for me to read then again I
never follow the tutorials and I almost
always get lost right for me at least
I'm making progress now okay this looks
complicated and stupid what am I
supposed to do here
I know what I'm supposed to do here shut
up I know it didn't say something about
the way you move objects when you're
standing on it that probably would have
been important information to retain in
my brain but there's not much room in my
brain I've got two faces on my body and
I'm sharing all the brainpower between
the two of them hey is this how this
works is this how something goes yeah
I'm breakdancing as hard as I can with
feet holding on the oh ah I think I know
what it wanted me to do I think I might
have actually pushed it but this is it
there we go push for my sake oh come on
ah oh I'm so smart and perpetually
excited about my own intelligence oh
yeah okay follow you and fall down no
good human fall up oh I can make it yes
I made it surprisingly shockingly
talking to the whole world but I made
that a mark you gotta make it
mom are you gonna have a good job Margie
push button barking out pushing button
where's the Coderre the goddamn button
oh uh where am I going now what fresh
hell have I been delivered into how do I
got to put the Box on the button you
know this seems like very basical
tutorial stuff maybe I could get to the
actual game here I'll just surf on it
don't mind me I'm not actually lifting
it or anything
head boy this works just as well as
portal did when you're removing box
hello friend
Morgan you have fun markimoo boxes poink
oh I'm learning how to use an elevator
is this just like a humanity simulator
where you learn all the useless tasks
that we as humans do the most mundane
things possible replicated in a video
game oh joy is frabjous day everything
is gonna be a-okay
Eddie thank you there we go Marky jump
on bak ha ha Marky tried to have fun
with job but then remember Marky isn't
depressing spiral downwards of
nothingness perpetually following the
instructions to someone I don't know
just going to breakdance for fun hahaha
haha okay I did it hello hi friend
hahaha how are you doing ah ah yes okay
good bye now bye with my weird hairy
neck and shoulders I just I just realize
how hairy my neck and shoulders are
anyway ah mundane Josh Jimmy let her
away boy don't miss it
it's punching the wall in frustration in
my own life open up all can't go
sideways I do admit at least in this
virtual reality I got quite an ass and
that's all I really asked for in life Oh
thunk ah [ __ ] dog goddamnit Falls ass -
piece of [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] oh my foot
stuck really god damn it get my foot out
of there push the button
oh god it hurts help I'm really I'm
stuck how the Frick do I get out of here
can't push the goddamn button push the
button push the button push the button
oh there we go everybody then
everything's a-okay forget I was
complaining about a damn thing haha Oh
decided to just do the Thriller walk you
wait there hey uh-huh yeah scoop the
booty okay
better be the last task that it has me
do because gun god this is dull drudgery
da da da da da da
da da da da [ __ ] [ __ ] god dammit hat get
me just can i huh son of a basket and
away we go
ah here we see the life of a normal
Markham oh he's really sad and has no
way to express his emotions other than
perpetual smile good job threatened that
gap good job being horrifyingly creepy
as usual alright we did it right point
looks like I'm wearing oven mitts I mean
it looks like a lot of more things are
going wrong with my entire body than
that but at least I got that going for
me head first into dance huh okay where
the hell am I now am i in purgatory this
seems like a perpetual wasteland where I
waste the rest of my good years away why
is this happening oh well whatever
at least it matches the inner to my soul
there we go is this just gonna be a boat
jumping puzzle or I gotta make it with
my stubbly limp noodle legs my instant
ramen body huh Oh an instructional video
I bet it's useless heaven
anybody huh climbing to VR properly you
need to get high
this instructional video was prepared
for everyone who does not feel high
enough I'm not high enough for this game
about their situation here climbing is
as easy as doing yoga
wow that is if it's being that yoga
where you started even if done properly
let's break it down raise your hands
I am approach the obstacle yeah lower
your hands grabbing the obstacle look
down to pull yourself up okay
pumping vigorously use your hands hand
release timing is crucial releasing too
early or too late will not get you high
and he might as well do yoga instead
okay so I'm going to get high by raising
my arms like I just don't care and then
humping the air that's what I understood
about this yeah I did it yeah I climbed
a rock whoa I'm the bestest huh I'm the
greatest there ever would look at me
doing parkour of this freerunning like a
boss freerunning like I remember all the
horrible things that have happened in my
life I can't get up the Skinner oh I can
I'm the best okay I don't know where I'm
going and I don't know why I'm going
there but I'm going as fast as I can go
hoping and even maybe praying that
there's going to be a payout at the end
of this road the end of this journey
when I'll finally be able to get some
bones and planted in my body
maybe one that would be great I couldn't
even get a spine and maybe I could get
my double face removed boy that would be
a dream unto a [ __ ] you almost made it
there you almost hit that in style
except you didn't and everyone's gonna
laugh at you if those even another human
left on this desolate wasteland we call
earth Oh an instructional video whoop
app not know haha Dart okay
give-give knowledge to me Oh undergone
higher I know you just did that I'm
already the best there ever was it
whatever the hell you're doing I know I
know I need to jump I did the thing it
just didn't look like I did it before
having no body and being 90 percent
jello it makes things awfully difficult
to be able to do normal tasks that you
take advantage of every day literally my
whole body is a giant floppy dick that's
all I've got and I don't have enough
blood in my body to make it never mind
yep that's a nice close-up of horrifying
this yep okay we made it Hey I guess
wait a minute hang on I see a secret or
maybe it's the way I'm supposed to go I
really know it's too early for Christmas
whoa it just looks like i'm so excitedly
running towards empty yeah hey all right
oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
sometime but I did it I got it I got it
okay cool yeah I don't know what this is
for but there's iron bars over here get
fell down huh bollocks I don't know if
I'm supposed to be here there's another
way down over there that's convenient
what happens if I just throw this off
the edge of the mountain would that be
nice
but anyone appreciate that or am I just
rebelling against the system and no one
actually cares have Liv take that screw
this what the [ __ ]
all righty then how's bizarre and weird
and cranes li arousing just hope all
right good Oh
all right yes oh yes oh [ __ ] Oh
okay there we go you can actually climb
up all right yes oh [ __ ]
HAP come on come on you can do it you
little up there get a little more there
we go
that's the stuff okay now let's not
screw this one up
ah okay good enough not great but good
enough oh boy
walk into the deathly sewers where I'm
sure my life is gonna be so much better
than it is now because it's already
horrible
hooray am I gonna meet a giant sewer
monster also known as an aloe gat or
gonna have this has this please thank
you all right who goes there it's gonna
be the scariest thing in here is just
gonna be my face staring at me from the
darkness yep I was right that's
horrifying
oh my god yeah how you doing what's that
I don't know what that is but I want it
what is this this is a blocky uranium is
this gonna be good for me to hold on do
also why do I have it okay whatever I
got him yay I did it
whoo-hoo I did it I said I said I said
okay I don't know why I'm doing it maybe
I was supposed to put these in the big
yellow container and keep them but I
kind of threw that thing off the edge of
the map I don't know I'm still here but
here I go where did I fall I do not know
oh hey wait a minute here
okay that's the place that blocked off
before that's where the thing what
goddamn in a win in our goddamn the
dead-end
seriously I I'm not not a hundred
percent sure but I'm I think I think I
I'm pretty sure I think that I am stuck
and I can't get out because I believe I
fell down a hole to get here and Wow I
am stuck aren't I
holy Shi F I fell down a hole to get
here well
bollocks to me I'm [ __ ] okay well
that's good to know
hey I get to stand here illuminated in
my own creepiness okay so that's
horrifying yeah okay so I think I'm
stuck but there's a lot more to be done
in this game and I could explore there's
potential for something cool to happen
here I just haven't gotten to it yet so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more of this game let
me know in the comments below and I
shall play it to the best of my ability
and thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video these turbo
it was a good first effort yeah